you know what don's on me i never did a
video on bloodstained ritual of the
night or curse of the moon why didn't i
they're great games they're awesome well
i suppose i had a
normal rotation of movie reviews didn't
feel like i had to
but now there's no normal rotation of
movie reviews so
i should talk about blood stained curse
of the moon too which i totally should
have done for bloodstained curse of the
moon and ritual of the night
[Music]
so bloodstained curse of the moon 2 is
the sequel to bloodstained curse of the
moon i feel like i'm gonna have to do a
history lesson
that's another reason i should have just
talked about the first games i wouldn't
have to do the history lesson in this
the review for the second game but i
digress so legendary game maker koji
igarashi was like i want to make another
castlevania game but
konami owns the rice to castlevania so i
can't make a castlevania game
so i need to make a not castlevania
castlevania game that feels like
castlevania but it's totally not
castlevania
but it's totally castlevania but not
castlevania so we put that up on
kickstarter and everyone was like
take my money so as this kickstarter was
for bloodstained ritual of the night
which was a total throwback to
castlevania symphony of the night it hit
a tier in which
now they're gonna make an eight-bit
spin-off game that is bloodstained curse
of the moon people loved that so much
they were like all right well
here's the sequel in such a grand sequel
it is it's really strange that this
8-bit spin-off that was just you know an
extra thing cause they hit that tier in
the kickstarter
is every bit as enjoyable for me it's
not as in-depth as blood-stained ritual
of the night but in its own ways
completely fulfilling so curse of the
moon 2 revolves around zen ghetto and he
has a couple of new friends now
dominique she wields a spear she also
kind of acts as a healer
robert he's the sharp shooter he's also
the clothy one like in
bloodstained curse of the moon one
grumpy gandalf he was the clothing but
he also had no distance well i mean he
had
pretty awesome spells but if you're just
going from melee yeah no distance so in
this game clothy robert he's a
sharpshooter so he has
guns so he can take out enemies from
afar though there's a bit of a load time
in between shots unless you get that
bandana special mood in which he just
starts shooting him up that's pretty fun
and hachi a big walking mech
when i saw the trailer i was like
walking mac that's that's strange but
folks it's not just a walking mech
it's a corgi in a walking mech he's a
puppy
a puppy gypsy could be in bloodstain she
cast spells it makes sense
danger well but aside the fact that
he's a dog and you know maths still
applies
he was actually one of my favorites you
know clothing grumpy gandalf from
bloodstained curse of the moon one he
had that move or a protective barrier
goes around him and i just kind of
kept him for that always but now super
mech puppy
has a move where he becomes invincible
and
that's pretty advantageous he also
floats which are some of the
all right the controls the controls are
top notch and what you would expect from
a not castlevania 3 castlevania 3
throwback type game but when you jump
you hold jump down
and super mech puppy floats which means
sometimes you're going to float and
you're not going to mean to float other
times you're going to mean to float and
you don't float and you just
point is a couple of pits happen kind of
gets annoying at first but you get the
controls down and it ceases to be a
problem at a point you may notice i'm
playing on casual mode yet my casual ass
i'm playing on baby diaper mode one of
the perks to go in casual mode is when
you
thread that needle and perfectly drop
down a series of pits
and you die twice
oh you can just drop the rest of your
crew down a pit and all right continue
infinite lives you're at the checkpoint
yeah it feels like cheating but it is so
much fun and like bloodstained curse of
the moon one
this game does draw at the run time by
making you go through the game
three times or so the logistics of why
and how it's executed are different from
bloodstained curse of the moon one but
still
it's the same kind of concept however
like with bloodstained curse of the moon
one when you go through you have
characters in the early levels you
didn't initially have so you find secret
paths alternate routes so the levels do
feel different though it's the level
you're now playing for the third time
the thing is it never bothers me that
would feel repetitive for any other game
but it's just bloodstain keeps it in the
pocket i never felt like oh gotta go
through the level again
i was always pumped at the opportunity
to go through the level again
perfect my craft memorize the level i
get a kick out of that with retro games
or games that throw back to retro games
is
i like going through the level so many
times that i just
know every nook and cranny of the level
how else are you going to find those
good
farming spots a good farm spot is a
tradition among retro video games as
well as i would argue a necessary
element in the in-game economy and
through your second playthrough and then
third playthrough
the bosses sequentially get harder and
harder like the first time you come up
against some of these bosses you're like
all right i'll go toe-to-toe
and i'm just banking on the fact that
i'm gonna hit them harder than they hit
me and
i won't die before they die like they're
gonna die first and you're just placing
your bets on that couple of scenarios
come down to that and that may be true
for the first time you fight some of
these bosses but by the second
definitely the third time you can't do
that anymore you need to learn the
boss's patterns they hit
harder their moves take up more of the
screen they're faster
you can't just go toe-to-toe you need to
master this [ __ ] and that feels so good
when a boss just
cleans you the [ __ ] out and you're like
there's no way
there's no way i can do this with what i
have but you keep trying and you learn
it and then you just beat his ass
because you know his pattern you get hit
maybe a couple times
that's an amazing feeling and blood
stain just it always gives me that and i
will say by the third playthrough that
this game makes you do
it is a continual story like with
bloodstained curse of the moon one
though you're going through the game for
the third time it's it's all part of the
same story
and by that third time it's pretty epic
the story itself is just an
epic one to the point where it's like i
gotta watch spoilers in this
8-bit game that's a throwback to retro
games the point is i'm invested you know
i'm invested with the bloodstained curse
of the moon series every bit as much as
i
am with the ritual of the night well i
guess i can't call it a series
ritual of the night has one game but i
imagine they'll make a sequel and i
would love to see a third curse of the
moon game
in fact i enjoy bloodstained curse of
the moon so much that with the first
game i got it for switch because that
was my kickstarter
my kickstarter tier that i donated to
you got to pick your system i picked
switch and it's a great game to play on
the switch and after i
sniffed around every corner of that game
and maxed it out i then got the physical
collector's edition on ps vita and i did
the same thing with that
also has a soundtrack oh yeah soundtrack
again with the masterfully constructed
catchy ass
music i feel like with bloodstained
curse of the moon
one there are three tracks i can think
of that are just
topped here i can't think of any tracks
in curse of the moon 2 that are as good
as the tr
the three tracks i'm thinking of with
curse of the moon one it might be
nostalgia at that point because i had
that soundtrack in my car for
months so we'll see how it goes we'll
see how the music grows on me as time
goes on
actually that's one of the one of the
downsides it's one of the big tragedies
of bloodstained curse of the moon too
curse of the moon one on the ps vita
it's such a perfect ps vita game it's an
amazing way to play it you know you're
wherever you are i've got time to kill
let me play bloodstained curse of the
moon it's a great
portable system game i know switch is
portable but
i mean portable's subjective at this
point you can't just put a switch in
your pocket
and cursor the moon too is not going to
it's not going to come out for vida
if limited run games wants to make a
special exception when they inevitably
come out
with the physical copies i wouldn't hate
a ps vita version
just saying totally not gonna happen a
man can dream
so bloodstained curse of the moon 2 it's
epic it's an amazing game it's a great
throwback but it's not a throwaway they
could have just you know half-assed this
retro game like all right oh that'll
appease fans
nah a lot of care was taken with this
you just feel like they put everything
into this game and they made a proper
sequel it's a 15
game and i keep that in mind when i'm
rating these things up which
means i'm putting more thought in into
my writing system which is the
conceptual antithesis to the reason i
created my rating system point is for 15
bucks this is some of the best 15
you're gonna spend like this isn't even
sale price fifteen dollars it's just
out the gate fifteen bucks i've gotten
more than fifteen dollars worth of
enjoyment out of it i love
blood stained i love ritual of the night
i love curse of the moon i love curse of
the moon too
if they can keep going give me a curse
of the moon trilogy i'll take that too
i still got three trophies to get before
i get my platinum
in uh curse of the moon two so i feel
like that was more of a flex
information uh one of those trophies is
going to be really hard there are
throwback games that are
throwback games and you just kind of see
them as such i don't even see
bloodstained as
a throwback game i see it as their
castlevania games to me same universe
dracula's dead and now we're dealing
with these threats that's just how i see
it it's worth buying at full price
absolutely but for 15 bucks that ain't
saying much because bloodstained curse
of the moon 2
is awesome tacular
and now i'd like to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by raycon
recon earbuds are those slick stylish
true wireless earbuds that start at
about half the price of other premium
wireless earbuds on the market and they
give you that sexy sound their everyday
e25 earbuds offer six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth powering more bass
and a more compact design that gives you
a nice noise isolating fit and as
variety is the spice alive as always
they come in a variety of fun colors
they're stylish and discreet no dangling
wires or stems
see they're in right now and i'm talking
normal i'm not even shouting
everybody who wears earbuds and talks
ever so they're great for working out
they're great for just relaxing
listening to music they're great for
putting in your ears sitting in the dark
listening to music that reminds you of
your childhood so you can
try to escape and forget about the
dumpster fire that is the year 2020.
yeah they're great for that too so click
the link below to go to buy raycon.com
john's to get 15 off your order and
thank you once again to raycon for
sponsoring this video
as always i do appreciate it alright so
bloodstained curse of the moon too have
you played it have you played the first
one have you played ritual of the night
we'll do a whole
blood stain questionnaire here whatever
you think of him comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you